لذلك عندما تنظر إلى كل هذه التكنولوجيا
لأنك منغمس جدًا فيها، هل
تثيرك أم تخيفك، أود أن
أقول الآن أنا
خائف قليلاً لأنني متحمس لقد استخدمنا
الكثير من أدوات الذكاء الاصطناعي الصغيرة والأصغر حجمًا والتي
تستهدف بشكل خاص تطوير
عملية الصور الرمزية الخاصة بنا لتسريع
سير العمل لدينا وزيادة
دقة خط أنابيب الوجه لدينا
لأننا نأخذ
أداء الممثل ونترجمه إلى
شخصية CG و  نريد أن تكون
دقيقة قدر الإمكان ولكن أعتقد أن ما
يحدث يغذي حقًا واحدة من
أكبر أمراضنا الاجتماعية في الوقت الحالي وهو
أننا لا نستطيع الوثوق بما نراه تعرفه من
التزييف العميق وما إلى ذلك والآن
مع  روبوتات الدردشة لن ​​نكون قادرين على
الوثوق بمصادرنا بنفس القدر ولكن الأمر سيصبح
أكثر صعوبة وأصعب مع
تقدمنا ​​لأنك ستشاهد في الواقع
مقطع فيديو يبدو
مقنعًا تمامًا ولا يمكنك تصديقه
الآن ما لم تكن حاضرًا جسديًا، كيف
تعرف أنك لست موجودًا، فأنت تعلم أن
الأمر يصبح هذا النوع من
الأزمات الظواهرية، صحيح
أعني أنك تعرف أه سقراط وأنت
تعلم دائمًا ما قال أنك تعلم أننا كنا
في مؤخرة أ  الكهف وكنا
نرى فقط ظل ما هو
حقيقي وأعتقد أن هذا هو المكان الذي
سنذهب إليه، ولن نعرف ما إذا كانت خلاصاتنا
دقيقة، أعني بالنسبة لي أنك تعرف أن هنري
كاساندرا وإريك شميدت كتبا هذا
الكتاب عن آي وواحد  من أكثر
الأجزاء إثارة للقلق هو أنه يتحدث عن كيفية
معرفة عصر النهضة
والتنوير حقًا، لقد
سمح التنوير للبشر باستخدام عقولهم
نعم وتبديد أه ما كان من قبل
نوعًا من صناعة الأساطير نعم الخيال،
كما تعلم ذلك عندما تنظر إلى  ظاهرة
مثل شروق الشمس اعتاد الناس أن يقولوا
حسنًا، هذا هو إله الشمس، نعم بالتأكيد
صحيح، ثم سيطر العقل وكنا
لا نستطيع أن نفهم سبب
حدوث ذلك، نعم مع الذكاء الاصطناعي،
سنعود تقريبًا إلى ذلك العالم الذي نعرفه
الجواب لكننا لا نعرف لماذا هو
الجواب لذلك سيخبرك الكمبيوتر أنه
يمكنك النقل نعم ولا يمكنه إخبارك ولا يمكنه
إخبارك بشكل صحيح
لأننا اعتدنا على الثقة
الدين نعم الآن نحاول، سننتهي
بالثقة في الذكاء الاصطناعي، هذا صحيح، لم نعد
نثق في الأسباب البشرية لأننا نعرف
مدى محدوديتها، نعم وقد
سألني الناس لأنني قمت بفيلم يسمى The
Terminator in Terminator 2 حيث السماء في
الشر الخارق  الذكاء الخارق القادم من
المستقبل كان يتلاعب بالماضي
للحصول على النتيجة التي يريدها
ودمر الإنسانية في
حرب نووية، حسنًا، لا أعتقد أن الذكاء الاصطناعي العام
سيحتاج الذكاء الاصطناعي الفائق إلى استخدام
الأسلحة النووية في الواقع، هذا سيفعله.  لا أريد
ذلك لأن النبض الكهرومغناطيسي
من شأنه أن يمحو الكثير من
البنية التحتية الإلكترونية الخاصة به، وأعتقد أنه
سيفعل بالضبط ما يحدث
الآن ويجعلنا ندمن على أجهزتنا، كل
هاتف، وأولًا وقبل كل شيء، إذا نظرت
حولك في أي مكان، ستجد الجميع دائمًا على
هواتفهم  لذلك تم إطلاق الجرس على القطة
بشكل صحيح وهم ووهكذا فإن هذا مجرد
تسليم المفاتيح في ذهني إلى
دكتاتورية تكنو أو نظام استبدادي من
نوع ما والذي يمكن أن يديره بسهولة
بواسطة كمبيوتر فائق لتحقيق غاياته،
وهكذا أرى نحن  في سباق تسلح جديد،
أي شخص يصل إلى هذا الذكاء الفائق
أولاً سيكون له الهيمنة على العالم،
وهذا ما قاله بوتين، وقد نقل عنه
قوله الآن كما
ذكرت ولكن ما أنا عليه هو أن الطريقة التي
ترى بها حدوث ذلك رائعة
هي  الآن أنت تعرف أنك لست بحاجة إلى
التغلب على الناس جسديًا، بل قهرهم
عقليًا، بالضبط، أنت تحاصرهم
عقليًا، نعم فقط انظر حولك في الحقيقة لقد
كنت أه اه، كما تعلم في
محادثة تحدثت في ذلك اليوم وعندما
طرحت هذا النوع من الأسئلة  لقد انتهيت
الآن كيف نعرف أن هذا لم يحدث بالفعل
من خلال الجلوس هنا ومراقبة
العالم، لا شيء مما يحدث هناك
يبدو منطقيًا للغاية بالنسبة لي
الآن كيف نعرف أننا لا يتم
التلاعب بنا من قبل الذكاء الاصطناعي العام الناشئ  تم
تطويره بالفعل، لا نعلم أنك
تعلم لأننا قد نكون في حالة
محاكاة جيدة أو قد نكون في
حالة انتقالية إلى محاكاة،
وهذا سؤال آخر ما إذا كنا
بالفعل في وضع تنظيمي، نعم، على الرغم من
أنه يبدو جيدًا جدًا، كما تعلم  إذًا،
أين الطرف المتفائل الذي قلته
أنك تعلم أنك تنتقل بين الاثنين، هل هناك
جزء منك يقول حسنًا،
أنت تعرف أن الذكاء الاصطناعي العام سيعالج السرطان
وكل ذلك، نعم، أعتقد أن الذكاء الاصطناعي العام يمكن أن
يفعل الكثير الكثير  من الأشياء التي لا يمكننا
فعلها، أنا مهتم أكثر بتطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي
فقط، ويجب أن
نشرح أن الذكاء الاصطناعي هو الذكاء الاصطناعي
AGI هو ذكاء اصطناعي عام
لا نحب الذكاء الفائق الذي
لم نحصل عليه بعد، كما نعتقد  ليس
لدينا ذلك بعد وربما لا
تعلمون، أعني أنني تحدثت إلى الكثير من
الأشخاص في الذكاء الاصطناعي
وهذا يخيفني لأنه بالنسبة لي
لا شيء فعلناه يمثل
تكنولوجيا تحويلية حقًا  لم
يتم تسليحها بالفعل كما رأينا معك،
تعرف الطاقة النووية وكل ذلك ولكن
فيما يتعلق بالذكاء الاصطناعي، فهي قوية جدًا جدًا، كما
تعلم أنهم فعلوا ذلك، ومن
الواضح أنهم أجروا دراسات حيث قاموا
بمقارنة مجموعة من الأطباء الذين يقومون بتحليل عمليات المسح
مع الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي تم تدريبه  لتحديد
الأورام وأشياء من هذا القبيل وتكون
نتيجة الذكاء الاصطناعي أفضل، لذلك في بعض هذه
المهام المتمثلة في النظر إلى مجموعات كبيرة جدًا من البيانات
والتوصل إلى الاستنتاج التحليلي الصحيح،
يكونون أفضل منا في
ذلك ويجب أن نعتمد عليهم هناك
ولكنهم  يجب أن تكون هذه الأدوات المنفصلة
في اللحظة التي نبدأ فيها بهذه
الأنظمة المتكاملة ونصبح معتمدين عليها بشكل كبير،
ستصبح دينًا جديدًا
وستصبح مثل فناني الفضاء عام 2001،
هذه المهمة مهمة جدًا بالنسبة لي بحيث لا
أسمح لك بتعريضها للخطر، نعم صحيح،
حاول بالضبط أن تتحول  نعم،
لا يحدث ذلك وقد تجد نفسك
محجوبًا خارج سفينة الفضاء،
يا
جيمس كاميرون، من دواعي سروري أن
أشكرك